opposition parties are taking a United
stand saying India's governing bharti
janta party is endangering democracy
this comes after parliament's decision
to disqualify the most prominent
opposition leader
Rahul Gandhi is one of the most vocal
critics of prime minister Narendra Modi
they have made all efforts to disqualify
Rahul Gandhi they want to silence him
for speaking the truth upholding
democracy protecting the Constitution
and fighting for the rights of the
people
on Thursday a court sentenced Gandhi to
two years in prison or defamation
relates to comments he made about modi's
surname at an election rally in 2019.
the BJP says the comments insulted
marginalized communities
will the members of backward communities
have to be humiliated due to their
surnames if a national party like the
congress party insults lower communities
and does not apologize because of their
ego can we call this freedom of
expression
[Music]
political parties say the government is
misusing institutions like courts and
investigative agencies to Target the
opposition
14 parties have filed a case against the
government in the Supreme Court which is
expected to hear the case on April 5th
the governing bharti janta party has a
majority in Parliament and is also in
power in Most states rights groups say
that under prime minister Narendra Modi
press Freedom has declined and the space
with dissent and criticism is also
shrinking and democracy has been
compromised many see the decision to
disqualify Gandhi as part of a trend to
silence critics ahead of Elections next
year
anybody who says anything contrary to
what the government wants to say comes
to some kind of agree for being
assaulted in a manner which had not been
seen before they get visited by
enforcement agencies like income tax and
Eed and others and the same thing is
happening with political parties
to appeal the defamation cases
quote the
vandya at any
costal Al Jazeera New Delhi